this is worth one mark and one mark only
okay
how are you expected to do this you're
expected to say
okay alpha x and h
and clearly all of these are the same
patterns it's exactly the same thing
right so i'll just do it for one
alpha x and h where do they reside on
this diagram
answer there's alpha there's x
there's h that's h
right so they reside together in a right
angled triangle
right so this is a question about right
angle triangle trig that's what they're
looking for you recognize
okay x alpha
h be careful with this what's the trig
identity
sorry the trig ratio that relates those
three pieces of infection together
answer now
the answer is tan or caught but
remember what i said about the
difference between demonstrating
understanding
and like just writing something down
which is correct but doesn't demonstrate
understanding
if i say do this right i can get a year
eight student
who has learned to manipulate like
equations right they can do that
and they can look at this and they can
say oh okay well clearly
cod alpha is x1h
they know nothing about trigonometry
they just read the question
and they can say well i know i know that
if you do one thing to one side of
equation you've got to do it to the
other
so therefore this is true do they know
what cut alpha is no they've never even
heard of tan alpha they've probably
never even heard of alpha
okay but they can do that my point is
this line demonstrates
no understanding okay
you might be pushing it a little bit if
you said this line
and you added on which was not necessary
but if you said
in what am i looking at oh we got names
it's the top name
um in triangle
okay this would be a little bit better
did anyone do this
did you get it did you get it
okay well we'll find out for you later i
suppose um
if you've done this that might be
a little bit better but still still i
i think you get this you essentially get
this for free
right if it's given to you in the
question
you're not going to get anything for
that and division
division and multiplication is not what
was being tested here
okay so therefore
what were you really expected to do
in the same triangle you should have
said
tan alpha is opposite
on adjacent
so then you take the reciprocal
and then you've got what did i get
then you've got your results
so so
i hope i have um convinced you of
why there's a difference like you're
like or ten what's the difference
answer you you receive this for free so
there is a difference in demonstration
of understanding
right so totally back that decision if
you can get that mark sorry
but i think it's legitimate let's move
into part two part three which are both
um
demonstrate questions show right what's
the result we want for part two
it's this
okay now when you look at this
remembering that you've
come from this part over here right
this looks to me suspiciously like
pythagoras
doesn't it you're a square root you've
got two squares under the square root
so this is not that complicated again
you can sort of backtrack a little bit
like where would this have come from
this two clearly actually belongs on
this side doesn't it
2ac where is 2ac on this diagram
a b is 2ac isn't it right there
and can i just say you see that it slaps
you in the face
as soon as you draw the diagram right
when you don't draw it you stare and you
stare and you're like are those bits
like oh wow those lines are really long
who knows what those mean and you don't
see it
okay you draw it and it's just there it
is
so all you would say is in triangle
which triangle is it
which one are we using a
b perfect right in a o b you invoke
pythagoras and you would say the
hypotenuse is
y squared right is equal to
x squared plus a
b squared happy with that yeah
um you can then take your y squared over
the other
side um what's this thing
this is two ac all squared
yep okay so so now you're almost
there aren't you okay we'll just
rearrange a little bit um we'll swap
this over the other side
we will take the square root if you
really want to be fancy
at this point you would say because ac
is greater than zero that's why you
don't need to take the negative
case and then you divide
okay so not not complicated once you see
the direction you have to go in
now when you look at part three
it looks it looks intimidating because
they've gone back to all of the
tans and cots and all that kind of thing
but all they're doing like it's all
interchangeable
because the x's and y's and the cots
they're all speaking the same language
you just need to rephrase things
okay so now where shall i do this i
really want my diagram still on the
board
okay
okay um again again you see that square
root on the bottom because you're trying
to um
you're trying to prove this
three what's that squared
okay now stay with me you see a square
root again
and you see squares under the square
root what are you thinking
you're thinking pythagoras again okay
it's not hard right
but clearly you're going to be in a
different triangle which triangle do you
think would be most useful to us
i'm thinking remember i did part one and
then i did part two
and then i did part three part two is
leaning due towards a particular
triangle
namely let's get another color
see there you go it's got ac in it it's
got x it's got z
and there is that sneaky right angle
right
because you're going uh at from this
point that's south
and that's east so they're at 90 degrees
they're perpendicular so it's hard to
see
right in that triangle in
triangle aoc invoke pythagoras you'd say
ac squared oops plus
x squared equals z squared right
i've talked before by the way about
writing your z's in a way that's helpful
to you you don't have to
but you better write your z's properly
ac i already know
what that is right so what's that going
to be y squared minus
x squared on 4 yeah
right which by the way that 4 is where
this 3 comes from you see where it's
going
plus x squared equals z squared what
should i do next
i've got a fraction there i'll get rid
of that okay so i'm going to go
y squared minus x squared plus x
i've multiplied by four and that's a
four
z square okay so now you can see where
where this comes from right so i've got
y squared plus three x squared
do i need to keep going from this point
there's just a straight substitution
of all of these pieces right the h's all
disappear because they're common
between all of them so you just divide
through by h squared okay
and then you pretty much just have to
shuffle things down do you want to do it
or are you okay yeah yes
okay yes you root it to make it easier
for you because
then you can get rid of the four z
squared
so you get a two you mean take the take
the square root here yeah yeah sure okay
so
please and it's true because you know we
already have the
this squared plus three of this squared
so i am ready to
swear it is it's a good point so i've
got this
and that's going to be 2z and again i
can say because
well i'll set the size because z is
positive
because it's a it's a leg okay it's a
side okay and now i'll just
i'll put in all of my uh yeah the edges
are coming out
anyway all right let's do it um here
here x y and z x y z
so i've got right
h squared cot squared
beta h squared
cot squared alpha three of them sorry
watch out for that
what do you got over here two h cart
gamma so far so good
yeah these h squareds are going to come
out from underneath the square root and
become an
h on the outside so that's
um
like so okay i've got my h here
now again just to be potential because
you guys should have an eye for detail
i'm going to divide through by h in a
second they're just going to disappear
but it's not disappearing because i've
divide i can like
why is it disappearing why can't i
divide through by h
because h is not zero it can't be zero
it's a lighthouse
right so because you can't just divide
through my numbers right you will lose
solutions
if and when h is 0. but h can't be 0. so
i've got this
i might as well at the same time divide
through by 2.
right so i've got caught out this gamma
here and the reason why is because
h is not zero and i'm there right i just
have to take the reciprocal
i'll put everything on the right side as
well uh sorry that's ten
tan we've taken the reciprocal so you've
got gamma two over
all of this stuff oops i wrote it around
the wrong way but